[Music]
you
[Music]
human papillomaviruses also called HPVs
make up a group of over a hundred
related viruses that infect people most
HPV s can cause common skin warts
usually on the hands or feet however
about 40 types of HPV infect the
genitals which are the sex organs on the
outside of the body
these HPV s cause the most common
sexually transmitted infections
illnesses transmitted from one person to
another through sexual activity
some genital HPV czar low-risk and may
only cause warts on and around the
genitals and anus of both women and men
rarely these HPV s can also cause warts
inside the mouth and throat other
genital HPV s are high risk they can
lead to cancer of the lower end of a
woman's uterus called the cervix less
commonly these HPV s can lead to other
genital anal or oral cancers in both
women and men it's important to know
that most HPV infections caused no
symptoms and the low-risk genital HPV s
that cause warts are not an important
cause of cancer
people infected with either a high-risk
or a low-risk genital HPV spread it
through skin-to-skin contact during
vaginal anal or oral sex for infection
to occur HPV enters through tiny cuts in
the skin around or inside the penis
vagina throat or anus
the virus makes its way down to the
cells in the bottom or base a layer of
skin and infects them as the infected
cells divide the virus begins to make
copies of itself eventually the infected
cells move up through the skin layers
releasing new viruses that can spread
the infection to other cells for most
people the cells of the immune system
can destroy the infected cells along
with the virus within 2 years but in
some people the immune system isn't able
to destroy all of the viruses leading to
an infection that doesn't go away
HPV infected cells may multiply over
several weeks or months
if the cells are infected with low risk
HPV they begin to form warts around the
genitals
if the HPV is high-risk it may damage
the cells genetic material causing the
cells to become precancerous over a
period of years a cancerous tumor may
slowly form as the damaged cells
continue to multiply the most common
cancer from high-risk genital HPV is
cervical cancer
there is no cure for any type of HPV
infection
however the Gardasil vaccine can help
protect against two of the most common
high-risk HPV s that cause genital
cancers the vaccine also helps protect
against two of the most common low risk
HPV s that cause genital warts
for best protection preteen girls and
boys should receive three doses of the
vaccine over a period of six months
before any sexual activity takes place
the vaccine injects dead proteins from
HPV viruses into the bloodstream
these proteins don't cause infection but
the proteins do stimulate certain immune
cells to create markers called
antibodies that can identify these HPV s
later if the live versions of these
viruses invade the skin the antibodies
recognize and attach to them
these immune cells destroy the marked
viruses which prevents an infection from
happening it is important to note that
the vaccine does not protect against
other types of HPV not included in the
vaccine the vaccine also doesn't
reliably treat cells that are already
infected
high-risk genital HPV s that cause
cervical cancer are most treatable when
diagnosed early women should have a Pap
test to see if their cervix has abnormal
or precancerous cells even if they've
had an HPV vaccine check with a health
care provider to find out how often to
get this test during this procedure a
healthcare provider will collect a small
sample of cells from the cervix
these cells will be examined under a
microscope to see if they're abnormal or
cancerous
a separate HPV test will look for
genetic material from high-risk types of
HPV when a Pap test and HPV test are
done together
it's called Co testing if these tests
show abnormal cells a healthcare
provider will recommend specific
treatment based on the woman's age
medical history and the abnormality of
her cells while there is no cure for an
HPV infection both abnormal and
cancerous cells can be treated some
types of HPV can cause common skin warts
or genital warts the warts may go away
without treatment as the immune system
fights off the HPV infection if the
warts are painful or don't go away visit
a healthcare provider so they can
examine the warts to determine the best
way to remove them although you can
treat common warts at home do not treat
genital warts yourself procedures to
remove either common warts or genital
warts include freezing with cryotherapy
burning with an electric current called
electrocautery
or by surgical removal
for more information talk to a
healthcare professional